Luke here at the outdoor boys YouTube
channel and today we're reviewing the
cheapest and most expensive baby on
amazon.com
[Music]
welcome to another episode of the
outdoor boys YouTube channel and today
we're gonna be reviewing babies that's
right a lot of you guys out there have
expressed some interest in starting
families or maybe you want to add to
your family and people asked me Luke
what's the best baby to buy now one of
the best places to buy babies online is
amazon.com and we buy most of our stuff
through there but there is a huge
spectrum of types and makes and models
and price ranges and it can be a little
overwhelming when you're trying to pick
a baby so we're gonna go ahead and buy
the most expensive and the cheapest baby
on amazon.com and we're gonna review
them and see what do you really get for
your money so first off guys let me show
you the cheapest baby on amazon.com the
baby boy in a gift box with shirt and
pants the Caucasian model so we are
looking at him at $9.99 and you can get
him with a couple days delivery with
Amazon Prime
well based on the pictures it looks
pretty good doesn't that look like a
good baby yeah but you never really know
so we're gonna go ahead and add that to
the cart
alright so here we have the most
expensive baby on amazon.com it's thirty
six thousand five hundred and ninety two
dollars and ninety five cents
Limited Edition handcrafted baby boy
with Egyptian cotton designer sleeping
gown by Paradise galleries but for
thirty six thousand dollars who it Duff
it better be something special so let's
uh let's see what we get
[Music]
we'll miss these the babies whoa all
right well which one should we start
which we start with the expensive one
yeah all right let's open up the
expensive one okay all right okay guys
rest start with the $36,000 baby okay
[Music]
the first thing I noticed right off the
bat it didn't come with its Egyptian
cotton sleeping outfit it seems to have
some sort of uh what is this a a onesie
oh oh the balance is really good on it I
mean look at that he sits up he sits up
right out of the box
that's um you don't see that in a lot of
the cheaper model babies a lot of the
cheaper babies fall over just like that
so there's a lot of babies on the market
and frankly some of them are kind of
ugly but this is a really cute one there
is a little bit of a scratch right there
on the temple that might have been from
shipping we're not a hundred percent
sure or how I opened the box with the
knife I probably shouldn't have done
that
that should be easy to repair that
shouldn't be a big deal one thing you
notice about these high-end babies is
they're really heavy I mean they don't
look like they should weigh that much
but oh man he is he is heavy so let's go
try some durability testing
look at that he's holding up really well
I mean that's that's just great a
construction right there what this baby
gets hurt in this thing rockabyebaby to
him ready I'll cheers him up so good
work yeah that's a great design I mean
all the limbs seem to really be fitted
on tight the head sturdy when selecting
babies you want to be really careful and
getting one that has a really good paint
job because you can see here this three
year old baby
it's paint is already starting to chip
here and there yeah and that's just you
know we ended up having to put all these
band-aids on it because if you keep just
keeps picking at it all right guys let's
open up the $10.00 baby and see what we
got okay decided Tom let's check now
what we got here oh yeah well the first
thing I notice about the $10 baby is he
seems to really be enjoying the packing
paper so I'm glad they included that in
there to give him something to chew on
and shipping but let me put him down and
go over some of the features that of
this $10 baby first off the looks of the
baby are a lot different than what was
advertised online but still it's a 30
inch baby boy and appears to be
functional but it's missing any of the
accessories it didn't come with clothes
like it was advertised also if you turn
the baby over the hair is really
splotchy and there's a little bit of a
bald spot
right there so definitely some
manufacturing issues there with the hair
but otherwise it seems you know
sufficiently chubby a really decent
monobrow so that's you know that's okay
despite some of the false advertising
that came with this baby it's actually a
pretty decent design so we're going to
go ahead and try some of the durability
tests and see how the baby holds up
this baby seems a little bit bouncier
than the other one which is surprising
you would think that the $36,000 baby
would have a stronger leg after a couple
hours in the balance test there have
been one problem developing the baby
appears to have been spring some sort of
leak the valve or something maybe some
hydraulic fluid is coming out right
around the mouth area and the whole
front of the baby is really wet look at
this oh yeah right in here oh yeah look
at this there's more of that fluid
definitely shaking this baby jumping
that sort of thing definitely seems to
be causing a lot of leakage out of the
mouths but once again I think that's
gonna be a cheap and easy fix one thing
you immediately notice about the ten
dollar baby is it requires a lot more
maintenance both in feedings and
changing and bathing so definitely be
prepared to spend a lot more time and
upkeep if you want to save money on
children
well guys in summary the ten dollar baby
is more maintenance it's got a little
bit of durability issues but at the end
of the day it's ten dollars guys and
it's still a healthy baby boy
I think we're gonna go ahead and keep
the ten dollar baby what do you think we
should name them take all right we're
gonna go ahead and call this one Jacob
well as much as I love the look and feel
thirty six thousand dollar baby can buy
a lot of fishing gear for thirty six
thousand dollars so we're gonna go ahead
and return it all right all right guys
who wants do plenty to ten dollar baby
we hope you guys enjoyed this video and
hopefully it gave you some clues on
which baby to pick I'm gonna put links
in the description to all the different
babies we featured in this video also if
you enjoyed this video check out some of
our other great videos including how to
trap and relocate children in case you
get a taller infestations there's some
great tips on how to deal with that
we're gonna be doing lots of traveling
lots of great adventures and lots of
great videos here from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and we put out new
videos every Saturday morning so don't
forget to
man